vous l'avez dit cyril tout à l'heure il
ya une chose qui est complètement dingue
avec cette émission c'est que chaque
année quand on finit la saison on se dit
on a passé une année de dingue l'année
prochaine c'est impossible que ce soit
encore plus fou inédit extraordinaire au
sens littéral du terme
et cette année encore ça a été
extraordinaire c'est à dire que on a
passé encore une année complètement
dingue
on n'avait pas vu évidemment arriver
cette pandémie qui est qui est
évidemment malheureuse mais qui pour
nous nous a fait aussi vivre des moments
hors du commun
donc on a encore réinventer pmp on a
vous l'avez réinventer avec
immédiatement envie d'aller voir les
téléspectateurs et pas les lâcher avec
halo baba maintenant cdu qui sait que du
tiff enfin à chaque fois il se réinvente
il se passe des choses ce serait un
vente et à chaque fois nous on vit des
aventures professionnelles évidemment
mais aussi humaine est bon je crois que
tout le monde le sait et on n'arrête pas
de se dire et on le redit encore une
fois mais au-delà de l'aspect
professionnel c'est une vraie aventure
personnelle avec des gens que on que
j'aime
voilà autour de la table géraldine bien
évidemment vous le savez mathieu jean
michel que j'aime infiniment d'âge alors
on a très peu de temps 10 secondes
chacun en tout cas mais merci au tessin
terreur d'être là et merci et deux
publics nous manque ce hlm on adore
faire des émissions publiques benji d'un
mois à moi c'était une année de haut
parce qu'effectivement les émissions
depuis chez soi en short tee-shirt
ça restera un grand moment et c'est vrai
que il ya eu un avant et un après quand
on voit les images on dit ça c'est le
monde ah bon on voit les gens dans la
rue qui se prennent dans les bras
j'attends c'est vrai que j'ai pris djoko
dans les bras donc voilà donc c'est à
ces mots ce sera une année je pense
inoubliable parce que on vivra j'espère
j'espère plus jamais ça et en tout cas
merci parce que j'aurais été fort à
l'inertie en belgique d'avoir été là
aussi pendant le confortement et d'avoir
répondu présent ce soir
vivement l'année prochaine évidemment
vous avez annoncé de lass ne serait que
de l'adar cas j'espère que encore dalle
passe pour ce qu'elle bossait quand même
très disponible moi c'était tout à fait
particulier parce que je suis arrivé en
janvier
et puis donc j'ai fait deux mois en
plateau voilà deux fois par semaine
d'après vous après confinement et moi
était confiant c'est à dire tous les
soirs j'étais avec vous en zoom de chez
moi avec les enfants derrière etc et
c'est pas c'est improbable incroyable
merci pour votre confiance et puis merci
à tous les chroniqueurs de m'avoir
accueilli par la bande sur sympa comme
ça parce que non mais je sais que c'est
compliqué quoi d'arriver dans une
famille comme ça qui est déjà formé
certains sont là depuis dix ans d'autres
cinq ans et moi je suis arrivé j'ai fait
quoi 2 me seront plus là donc merci à
tous que c'est ce que c'est chaque arabe
a été considérable a très bien accueilli
kelly moi ce que j'ai remarqué cette
année c'est qu'on suit tous dit de temps
en temps c'est qu'on a vraiment une
équipe de ouf on s'est vraiment dit que
cette fois-ci balayon on est vraiment
apaisé on s'aime vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup mais vraiment tous en voiture
ça ça fait du bien il n'y a pas de
brebis galeuses et en guise à ce que
j'ai ce que je me dis que c'est ma
troisième année et là je veux si je suis
là l'année prochaine c'est ma quatrième
je me dis que le temps passe
hyper vivent à vos côtés aux côtés des
chroniqueurs et c'est juste un truc de
dingue ce qu'on vit et cette année je
sais que l'année prochaine ça va être ça
va être encore mieux et je kiffe
c'est vrai que c'est une dernière un peu
particulière parce qu'on peut faire la
fête comme d'hab mais on fera une très
très grosse rentrée vous inquiétez pas
on fera la fête avec vous avec le public
qui sera avec nous oui un dernier mot
merci maintient ses propos les bons
moments parce que vous avez quand même
beaucoup de fidèles ils vous attendent
et bien chaque fois j'ai l'impression
que tout se renouvelle plus ou moins on
arrivait ici on ne savait pas ce que ça
allait donner sans public
il ya une belle énergie on s'est
découvert des caractéristiques on s'est
vraiment beaucoup amusé et puis
et puis vivre l'année prochaine
exactement on voit qu'ils sont ou
seraient les prochaines collectes
bernard non parce que j'ai envie de dire
simplement c'est que la mission est
remplie je crois qu ont diverti les gens
sans prétention tout l'histoire moi je
voi et je commence à m'intéresser aux
réseaux sociaux est tout ce qui se
raconte dessus les gens s'amusent
beaucoup appuyé décrit une lettre sur
lui après qu'il en est vraiment divertir
ici là il a pris deux mois c'est à moi
c'est sûr quand on perd les choses qu'on
se rend compte qu'elle lequel nous
manque
moi j'ai détesté le confinement je dis
très franchement j'ai moyennement vécu
effectivement c'est pendant le
confinement me suis rendu compte que je
mets la solitude mais j'étais pas un
solitaire
donc effectivement faire l'émission seul
chez soi et plus avec la bande là c'est
à ce moment là je me suis rendu compte
que c'était un rendez-vous qui manquait
et que ça m'a fait de la peine
et puis je vais je dire un mot aux fans
mais pour une fois qui est sérieux parce
que je trouve que quand c'est des
moments les fans suivent et hélas quand
tout va bien et le vrai c'est celui qui
est là quand tu dis une connerie quand a
dérapé quand tu as moins bien et cela
raté pmp ils sont tout le temps là
conditionnerait en direct la rezaï te
soutiennent quand même est moche ça bien
de soutenir aussi des gens qui ont du
temps à l'échec c'est vrai bras merci à
vraiment vous êtes vraiment je vous dis
une exceptionnelle vraiment et la
famille s'agrandit toujours ce qu'il ya
plein de gens aussi qui critiquait dans
l'émission et qui viennent nous voir et
qu'ils disent en fait ceux qui
critiquent c'est souvent ceux qui n'ont
pas vu l'émission et merci à vous de
votre soutien
oui j'ai chez moi ce qui m'a épaté ses
vous en faites pas on ne rit en fait je
trouve que de plusieurs c'est de durer
et moi je vous observe aussi un peu
comme une sorte de spectatrice en fait
vous avez une faculté quand même à vous
réinventer quand il ya eu cette crise
vous avez réinventer la manière de faire
de la télé la manière d'après de revenir
en plateau son public cette année entre
btp la rigolade l'adar cas il ya un côté
quand même chez vous visionnaire parfois
vous vous plantez mais quand même
globalement ça mais aussi incroyablement
à prendre ou à laisser
et quand même un énorme succès et je
trouve que c'est assez impressionnant
d'observer ça en direct comme ça et de
voir quelqu'un qui malgré tout depuis
dix ans 12 ans fabrique la télé est
réussie on se régale avec pierre
tunisien
un peu trop de chamois pour terminer à
merci j'ai simplement plaisir ma chérie
tu sais que c'est sincère
mathieu mais c'est surtout à la raison
faut te reconnais bien là d'autres
défauts mais pour reconnaître que
revenir avec les boîtes revenir avec
tuchan les choses il sent les choses à
la télé tu sens le rythme du sens des
choses voilà ma mère si mes chéris et
tout cas je voudrais remercier c'est
surtout les téléspectateurs aussi qui
nous soutiennent à fond et qui sont là
dans tous nos projets de mercy